uh mr duvall
you're in the american film institute's
top 100 movies more than any other actor
you have six i'll tell you the six do
you know him godfather one or two
apocalypse uh kill a mockingbird tender
mercies
not tender mercies
and mash talk to me a little bit about
godfather i know we've touched on this
before but uh bruce stern paul newman
and steve mcqueen all were considered
for the role of tom hagan you beat them
all out yeah they wanted to name it
coppola wanted me yeah he wanted you you
beat them all out here's a fact people
forget i bet you remember this al pacino
james khan and robert duvall were all
nominated for best supporting actor joel
gray won that year for cabaret i mean
the godfather's the greatest movie of
all time one of them and one of you guys
should have won right i mean it's a
little could be yeah yeah thing though
the year i thought i could have won the
supporting actor was uh was for uh
apocalypse now i didn't get it yeah
do you know i won the english academy
award for that you know you were on
screen in that movie for 11 minutes it's
the le and it's the most memorable
character in the [ __ ] movie well
brandon was great though yeah he was
fine especially in the redux when they
re-edited it yeah but you know everyone
quotes you when you hit the beach and
you're carrying on like a lunatic i love
the smell of my pum in the morning does
it hurt you when you lose uh well you
yeah it depends
when you won the award where'd you put
the award in my farm in virginia i have
it on the mantle is that right facing a
letter from brander that i like even
better than the other what did brando
say in the letter i'm not gonna tell you
you loved him yeah we are like jimmy
khan said recently if you didn't say you
were influenced by brandon you're lying
because he was like our mentor brando
never would memorize his line i don't
know how you do that i can't brando used
to put this and this this and this he'd
look at the lines we'd change him and
he'd we'd have to stay cut and luca
brazil said may you have a beautiful son
and i hope that their first child
be a masculine child we made him stick
his tongue out saying [ __ ] you
you would go and change brando's cue
cards yeah
brando would write things down now is
that being lazy was brando a lazy actor
yes and no go ahead what do you mean he
said he was always searching but it was
kind of lazy but it worked for him yeah
he because he was so good he was able to
it was so good but you would never do
that
i tried it once it didn't work you did
because
how much preparation does it take for
his scene because if you have let's say
i like to memorize it
and i like to improvise too but if it's
good script like lonesome dove or
something you don't have to improvise
how long does it take you when you have
a dense scene i mean when you have like
almost a monologue how long does it take
you to memorize something like that it
takes me a while and when we did the
movie the judge i had a lot of stuff to
learn and you learn it and you go off
and you study and that's the job that's
the game and then you have to keep in
touch with yourself
now now talk to me about uh bill murray
for a second
jimmy khan the two funniest guys i ever
worked for i haven't really yet but
they're funny guys but murray says uh
he describes robert as a time bomb you
a time bomb on the set really he said
you're so serious with everyone that you
you scared everyone on the set that
people were afraid of you that's not
necessarily true are you a scary guy i
think you are intimidating no no no you
you're a manly guy
no no the point is if people are getting
in your way especially some directors
yes
you know i work with the director once a
true grit way back he didn't say it to
me he said it to another when i say
action tense up god damn it can you
imagine a guy coming in here your boss
saying tense up when you do this that's
the worst thing you can say to an actor
all right back up about true grit you
were actively fighting with john wayne
during that movie
true or false that's the rumor no you
guys did not get along well because
wayne thought you were pain in the ass
you were fighting with the director all
the time no he said and he laughed he
said he got the boys dander up no i i
got along fine with her it was it was a
director that was a but when you go on
the center
i got along with wayne what are they
talking about well what happened with
the director you're fighting with him
all the time well the guy was a jerk
what do you mean he was a jerk well a
lot of those old directors say they were
like authorities you know authoritative
then you work with a guy like coppola he
turns the process around and lets it
come from you to see what you do so do
you stay in character when you're on the
set no no i don't like don't you hate
that [ __ ] when they do that well
sometimes you're thinking about
something but you know daniel day-lewis
he's a very good actor but you know he
does that does that annoy you sometimes
i mean like you're working with a guy
let's say like daniel day lewis or some
type like that and you know you go over
hey buddy everything was good he starts
behaving like abraham lincoln you go say
abraham lincoln
crazy
nah that's his way of doing it everybody
has their own way of doing it but you
don't believe in that no what is it gary
please i'm going to show you i'm going
to show you a picture we just tweeted
this out but this is from the set of the
godfather it's mr duvall wearing the cue
card
oh my goodness
oh there you are you're holding you're
where you're actually wearing the cue
card
that's true yeah that's great
oh my god you know our cue card hold on
brando love jimmy khan right jimmy's a
kind of and jimmy would tell a joke and
take brando three seconds to get it then
they're gonna